- DRock and I
decided, excuse me,
DRock decided that
Sunday wasn't a lot.
Obviously we're
here Saturday, Sunday.
(children cheering)
This is so awesome.
Sunday was a day where
very religious country,
not a lot going on but
we did an incredible thing.
I went to a waterfall
which I've never seen before.
That was a whole lotta fun and
it was just a nice rest day.
A nice day to jam with the
team but most of all waterfalls.
(rap music)
- [Man] You got to
do what you got to do.
- Brandon, just saw
a snake and a big one.
- [Brandon] No, really?
- Yeah.
- [Brandon] No.
(group chatter)
I didn't see a snake.
("Standing Still" by Metsa)
- That was when I
was like oh my God,
oh my God.
I was in New Orleans
with a bunch of friends.
I was like
screaming at this bar.
Like ah, I'm going to Africa.
First time ever.
(group laughter)
I was so excited.
- [Gary] You were
just sitting at your desk.
- [India] No, you sent
it on a Sunday that's why.
- [Gary] Oh, we
sent it on a Sunday?
- [Group] Yeah.
- [Gary] Oh that's good.
What were you doing?
- I was a runner-up so
I find out we leave,
Claude called me at
like 10 o'clock at night.
She was like, "We're
taking another person."
I'm like, "That's amazing."
- [Gary] That's so awesome.
- But very unexpected.
- [Gary] That's awesome.
What about you, Dio?
- [Nick] I was at my apartment.
It was a Sunday.
I think it was
football Sunday night.
- [Man 2] Sunday night.
- And I was like with all
my boys and I started losing my
shit and there was
nothing happening on the game.
- [Gary] Right.
It's like a holding penalty.
- They're like what's
going on and I was like,
"I'm going to Africa."
And they were
like, "Cool, dude."
- [Gary] Yeah.
(group laughter)
- Like none of them got excited.
- [Gary] Yeah, such dudes.
- I was like so (inaudible).
- [Gary] What
about you, Brandon?
- Yeah, it was awesome.
- [Brandon] Where was I?
It was Sunday night, Eagles had
just played and Claude texted
me, she was like,
"Check your email."
I was just like "Oh God."
- [Gary] A headache?
- What could possibly gone wrong?
I'm like it's a Sunday night.
- [Gary] You're
like (censored) up to?
- (censored) I was like oh God.
Should have
checked online earlier.
(group laughter)
And I was like one
day with my wife, you know?
I did, I checked
my email, I freaked out.
My wife remembered the night
I applied was my birthday.
- [Gary] Yeah, yeah.
- And I was like Jackie do
you remember I was telling you,
I told her the
whole time she was like...
She was in complete shock.
Where?
Ghana!
Absolutely freaking out.
- Bri, what about you?
- [Brian] Same thing.
Sunday night I got
a message from Claude.
It was the kind of thing
that I totally forgot about it.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- And I was like
holy shit, I'm going.
So it was interesting 'cause
the lay off was like
two days previous.
- [Gary] Sure, sure.
- So I was like the
chosen one from L.A.
it was interesting.
- [Gary] Celeste
were you in L.A.
at that point?
- [Celeste] Yeah, I was.
- [Gary] Okay.
Hussain, what about you?
Where were you?
- (inaudible)
told me at the gala.
But toward the end of
the gala so we (inaudible).
We were dancing, whatever.
And she was like guess what?
I was like, "What?"
"You're going to Ghana."
And I was like, "Why?"
(group laughter)
- [Gary] Yo, this is so scary.
I understand.
So Boyd, you were
what in studio in Atlanta?
- No.
- And you're like
21 Savage, great news.
(group laughter)
- [Mike] It was actually
at the pre-gala event,
the night before.
- Yep.
- [Mike] So I asked Natalie.
(inaudible)
- [Gary] Yeah.
- [Mike] So I had briefly met
him a couple times before and
I asked, "Can I go
talk to him real quick?"
After I reintroduced
myself she was like,
"We're going to
bring you to Africa."
And I was like, "What?"
She had to say it five times.
I was eventually
like this is a joke.
(group laughter) I thought
they were just playing with me.
- That's awesome.
(group chatter)
So they told you
ahead of time, right?
- [Mike] Yeah.
- I see.
That's really cool.
Axel, what about you?
So yeah, I was home watching
football with my fiancé.
We actually had just gotten
engaged like the week before.
Just gotten back from our trip.
Got a couple texts,
"You're going to Ghana."
I say, "Fuck yeah."
I got all pumped
up and she's like,
"You're leaving
me for five days.
"That's not right, no.
"I don't want you to go."
- [Gary] That's awesome.
- I was like,
"Too bad. I'm going."
- [Gary] That's awesome.
Nature's like whack.
I want that t-shirt.
Nature is whack.
You need to have some
purple drank on your...
If we took Pam to
Mississippi they'd be like, "Yo."
("Standing Still" by Metsa)
Fun trip, huh?
No, I've never hiked, bro.
This is like my first hike.
I was such an
outdoorsy kid, too.
Like this is the kind
of place I would play in.
The woods, I love the woods.
I'm very comfortable in
it because of my childhood.
Like I was super
into let's play G.I. Joe
and Star Wars and stuff like...
I made up this game when I was a
kid called adventures where four
of my friends would follow me
around like this and I would
make up narratives.
We'd have to make
a viral video, DRock.
I feel like a rant
in the jungles of Ghana.
(group laughter)
You're complaining about shit.
Look, where the fuck I am.
Holy shit, what's over there?
That's like rad shit.
Like we're in it.
That was a good
episode the other day.
We're pumping out some
new interesting content.
- [Brandon] I listen
to the whole thing.
- [DRock] What'd you think?
- [Gary] Yesterday,
yeah it was great.
The Jersey.
AMAs are good too.
That was really good.
The Reddit thing.
- [DRock] I think the
documenting (inaudible)
this all the time.
- [Gary] Yeah, I hate that
we posted it on a Saturday.
We should've
been smarter about it.
- [Brian] What?
The AMA?
- [Gary] But I think it's
going to go viral by itself.
- [DRock] It'll be fine.
Why? You don't think
people watch on Saturday?
- [Gary] Right, I think--
- [DRock] Really?
- [Gary] I think
but I could be wrong.
That's just a
completely intuitive thing.
I don't like that
we launched it with
me not being around
to really promote it.
("Standing Still" by Metsa)
- [Brian] Thousand bees.
Thousand ants
for that one thing.
- [Gary] This is awesome.
- [Axel] Those fire ants? No.
- [DRock] I don't think so.
It could be pretty dangerous.
- [Gary] The ultimate thing when
we think we have something is
giving me an hour on
live while it launches.
Right?
- [DRock] Yeah.
- That's where I think I can do.
That rant at the end of the
episode the other day has gotten
some attention.
- [DRock] Has it?
Yeah.
- [DRock] Yeah, it's good.
- Like I don't
give a fuck about,
not a fucking
teeny bopper with a vlog.
I'm starting to realize
this is one thing I could do.
I would move to any land if it
was actually purely positive.
I don't know.
It just makes me so happy.
Like it makes me
disproportionately happy for my
guys to have a good time.
Or like when somebody...
I feed off of positivity.
Literally what goes through my
mind is like I want to go in
there and play with G.I. Joes.
And Star Wars figures.
Straight up.
I was only into
G.I. Joes for six months.
Mine was mainly Star Wars to
wrestling figures to Nintendo.
When I think about my core
childhood toys it was
Star Wars figures, oh,
this is fucking rad.
This mushroom.
Should we eat that?
Who wants to eat that?
- [Brian] That looks scary.
- [Gary] I would eat it.
- [Hussain] How much?
- [Brian] You would not eat it.
That's what we got to do.
- [Gary] If we're
gonna have fun on this trip.
Celeste, eat it.
- [Celeste] No chance.
No chance.
- [Brian] No?
- [Gary] Oh shit.
That's nice.
("Standing Still" by Metsa)
So sometimes you
just get to see
some rad ass shit.
You know, just kind of
separating myself right now from
the trip to bring
value for the vlog.
I think it's super important
to break your patterns.
Just gets you into different
mindset whether it's being
grateful and gaining perspective
or if it's just
enjoying yourself.
Going surfing for three days
with your best
friends from college.
Think it's massively
important to break patterns.
And I think when you're lucky
enough to be in a place where
you love what you're doing,
you don't need
it to like refresh.
You just, for me, it's offense.
It's not defense.
It's not like,
"Oh shit, I'm fried out.
"Let me go somewhere."
It's pure offense.
It's I'm happy but this gets
me different perspectives.
These give me different things
in my mind and whether it's
going away for three days to
like a football camp and trying
to be a quarterback or if it's
going to a place like Ghana
and visiting some
of the, you know...
As you guys know, I keep the
things I do that I'm a little
bit more proud of quite quiet.
It's just my style.
I don't think you brag
or promote the things you're
supposed to do a good human
being but I'm excited about this
kind of...
This is like a
three episode series,
right?
- [DRock] Mhmmm.
("Standing Still" by Metsa)
Anyway just for
all the entrepreneurs,
I know this is a little
break of more like vloggy stuff.
But breaking
patterns on offense,
not just doing it
when you're fried out.
If everything's
rolling right now.
If you had a good six months,
you caught my content in January
and you're rolling, this might
be the exact time to not hustle
all 24/7.
Maybe go to
e-Sports camp in Korea or
go learn how to
cook for a weekend.
Just breaking patterns gives
you a different perspective.
I think way too many people
think about things like that as
oh, I need this to rest
or I need this because
everything's so stressful.
I look at the reverse.
I think it's just good to taste
different things which gives you
new ideas.
("Standing Still" by Metsa)